my fellow comrades it's me PewDiePie
what's that there's something different
about me huh
it must must be the glasses Oh what
there's still something how they must be
the merch then you cyka blyat merch very
nice if you're a real sook add chicken
link in a description limited time
available only now let's get on with the
video
why are you crying listen up
okay the beard mean was getting old and
all memes must die so stop crying stop
being such a baby and stop crying do you
want to look like this huh pathetic why
do I look 12 then we're gonna take
anything I say seriously people keep
saying we need to stop making dumb
people famous but I always say but then
who are we going to laugh at who are we
supposed to ridicule and feel better
about ourselves because at least there's
one person out there that is doing worse
than me from people like sexy vegan to
jacksFilms to now woah Vicky
remember what Vicky Vicky whoa the girl
who thinks she's from african-american
descent in this hotel I knew it I knew I
was black I mean how could you not
remember such beauty and such grace for
those who you don't know who were Wiki
is she's a master of motivational speech
[Music]
she's a master in the art of dancing
and a master swimmer it's my favorite
club let's see what she's been up to
lately hmm
she was in a fight with Daniel Bragg Oh
Lee watch the cash me outside girl this
is some really interesting news
it's like water fighting water
is she wearing the hoodie like that aye
sir five-year-old there what is
happening where's your mom
can someone tell me why is there a
little kid here
cheese says martial artists will study
this video to learn the master fighting
technique that legend every day when
Daniel Greco Lee and what wiki had a
fight
but she comes from behind and tries to
hit well wiki right in our worst spot
which is where her hair is a lot of
people don't know this but well wiki's a
weak spot is located right there I guess
Daniel Berger must be studying us whoa
whoa I don't know if I should laugh or
cry at this it's just so ridiculous you
have all these adults involved as well
but nothing really gets stopped I don't
know how this is even possible piers for
the future here sorry to interrupt
have I told you about Ashe it's coming
out on every console ever in May check
it out link in the description join the
discord have some fun okay
keep going even video what week you had
the perfect response to this and the
most mature well-mannered way possible
which is what I expect from such a high
class character like whoa Wicky
let's watch whoa she says showing off
some of their the moves that she that
she displayed earlier and the fie
brilliant stuff really good technique
there you want to hit them as low and
fast as possible she just lost the fight
against herself there what is happening
she's fighting air and she's losing that
brick well done
how do you fall from that
it's really it really is the best way to
display dominance is to just fight there
kids stop thinking about the
five-year-old I need to find out I need
to find out who she is
little Tay is that her is that her
profile pic okay that's kind of
brilliant we live in a society we truly
live in a society
[Music]
I feel like I'm not I'm not allowed to
say anything cuz she's only nine years
old but she's flexing your momís also
around six years old I broke as hell but
one day I woke up I said to myself I'm
gonna be broke no more so I got out
after working hard moving bricks and now
we be living in the hail seat have you
y'all don't have have you and I'd be
holding your mama's right
this bag cost me a Lamborghini I mean
she's right about pretty much everything
she says so I don't really know what I
don't really have any counter points or
counter arguments here that bed does
cost more than a Lamborghini and she
does make more money than what my red
car broke ass y'all know like whoa whoa
I feel like anything that has lil in
front of it has some sort of chromosome
deformity there has to be some
scientific research on that to prove
that because stop hating on me if you
are flexing then aren't you technically
hating I feel like this whole Instagram
culture has just become it started off
as well parted but now it's it's like
they realize they can monetize their
boat our nation and they just play it up
even more and and then you have all
these these kids in the common just
hating like when they're obviously just
portraying a character or what's it
called exaggerating their whole shtick
or whatever usually will week at the end
of your video just smiling like haha
gotcha [ __ ] I just
helicopter you picture step taking a bus
you pitch is kind of fun it sort of
reminds me of the Westboro Baptist
Church you know holding their signs that
are hateful and everyone just hates on
them but they keep doing it because they
think they have a purpose for a I think
maybe I'm reading too much into this but
it seems like the same thing here cuz
they just keep doubling down on how how
dumb they can act and that makes them
more money and they think that ever
anyone that just hates them doesn't
understand that the fact that they're
just playing it up they're not actually
that stupid but in reality yes you are
you started this whole thing because you
were dumb and just because you're now
playing into it doesn't change the fact
that you are in fact incredibly stupid
but I always wonder is how do they
monetize it you know they're always
flexing money Instagram doesn't really
get you that money unless you do some
sponsor deal it's not like you have ads
on your photos or it doesn't matter if
your video gets a lot of views where
there's the money come from the only
sponsored posts I found is this one now
let's say new sponsored content just
watch okay I'll just need to do you like
oh yeah
[Music]
bread one is now go to subtitle this in
case you can't understand Bradish watch
a lot of our videos he's a big fan so he
will subtitle this for us this first
piece because I didn't get any of that
[Music]
okay so she has a song that's how she so
she got a record deal is that it who my
follow-up question is who buys the song
who's buying the song why would anyone
buy the song who is the consumer of the
song
[Music]
change I change I change our Beach
really good lyrics at least we get to
laugh at something sure they get money
and they get famous but we get good
entertainment this is great light this
is great stuff you have to appreciate it
[Music]
not having a bullet but you what you
ain't complaining about know how to make
it well wiki video
[Music]